con un visado humanitario polaco la
atleta violó rusa kristina chamán usca
ya abandonó este miércoles los juegos
olímpicos en dirección al exilio tras
dos noches en la embajada de polonia en
japón el ministro de exteriores polaco
aseguró que la corredora ya se encuentra
en varsovia refugio de varios opositores
al régimen de lukashenko
christina chimán usca ya aterrizó de
forma segura en varsovia quiero
agradecer a todo el personal consular y
diplomático polaco involucrado que ha
planeado y ha asegurado su viaje a la
perfección polonia continúa mostrando su
apoyo y solidaridad el trayecto de
chamán usca ya iba a ser directo desde
tokio hasta varsovia pero en el último
momento fue modificado con una escala en
viena por razones de seguridad con el
recuerdo todavía presente del avión de
ryanair que lukashenko desvío en mayo
para detener al opositor román
protosevich
durante los juegos la atleta criticó
decisiones deportivas de su federación
en consecuencia el domingo dos miembros
del cuerpo técnico bielorruso la fueron
a buscar a la villa olímpica y la
llevaron al aeropuerto en un intento de
repatriación forzada del que escapó con
la ayuda de la policía japonesa y del
comité olímpico internacional que ha
anunciado una investigación formal
hemos recibido un informe del comité
olímpico nacional que será evaluado
desde ahí y además el coi ha decidido
abrir una comisión disciplinaria para
esclarecer los hechos pax en skies y
para escuchar a los dos oficiales
artur showman y yuri moiseev y de que
estarían implicados en este incidente
el incidente sucede un año después de
que estallara nuevamente con fuerza el
movimiento ciudadano contra lukashenko
mientras el régimen está cada vez más
aislado a nivel internacional